let's go to our caller from the six five
zero
who's calling today from six five zero
yes are we on speakerphone this better
that is better thank you okay yeah so I
remember for my policy but my poli-sci
days that there was something in the
Constitution I can't remember exactly
what it was but there's something in
that said that if the government
basically just did a really poor job of
representing the people of the United
States and the people of the United
States felt that the government was just
overall corrupt that there's something
in there and I can't remember exactly
what it is and I'm hoping you might know
what I'm talking about that the American
people can basically flush the whole
government out of all the
representatives that we have in the
United States or we can remove everyone
from office one way or another is did I
remember that incorrectly does that not
exist
you know I unfortunately and we're not
familiar with exactly what you're
describing I mean I know about
provisions like the 25th amendment to
remove an individual for lack of fitness
but I'm not sure about this general sort
of you know flush the government down
the toilet and it's maybe 10 or 15 times
as Donald Trump says some people are now
flushing toilets 10 or 15 times I'm not
aware of that particularly okay well all
right then I'm probably mistaken or
probably maybe I don't you may be right
I just I'm not sure well if anyone out
there knows what I'm talking about I
think cuz especially if you know with
all these polls people are saying that
the majority of the people want the
President of the United States removed
from office and if our government can't
fulfill our desire as the people you
know they're supposed to represent us I
mean I think that's the I think it's a
huge disgrace for how the government's
supposed to work there's no question I
mean listen what you're pointing out is
that government does not really reflect
the desires of the individuals and this
is for a lot of different reasons this
is because of voter suppression this is
because
very often they just don't do what their
constituents actually want them to do
because of lobbyists influence and
campaign finance you're spot on there I
mean we we have the idea of a democracy
of a representative democracy and in
practice we we barely have it
yeah it's disgraceful we need a flush
them right now flush at ten or fifteen
times my friend all right thank you so
much for the call I very much appreciate
it let's go next to our caller from
let's go to the five one six area code
who's calling today from five one six
good I think that's me hi I'm Antoine
from Long Island
hey Antoine what's going on good
afternoon mister pac-man and Mary and
peach midday yeah yes indeed I really
just had a comment or a question I
should say it seems like the Republican
Party really only has two defenses right
now for what Trump had done it's either
that he really didn't revolt withhold
funds didn't alter a quid pro quo and
didn't act for a favor which have all
been shown to be false or everything he
did was okay they say that the poll was
okay that would Giuliani did was okay
and what he continues to do asking for
favors from other countries is fine so
my question to you is why can't we get
somebody like Nancy Pelosi I love Nancy
or Schumer or even better
AOC who's much better at controlling to
kind of just stand up on the House floor
and say hey Germany if you're listening
could if you get Trump's taxes I'm sure
you'll be mightily rewarded by the price
think somebody has don't even remember
that there was somebody who's sort of
tongue in cheek did that but you're you
know what you're pointing out Antoine is
is actually what their defense has been
for most things which is it definitely
didn't happen and then they transition
to if it happened it was okay and then
they transition to it happened but it's
fine this is not anything to get all
worked up about I mean
remember they said oh nobody had any
contact with Russians no no no no nobody
Trump said it from jr. said it pence
said it Jeff session said it and then it
switched to listen yeah I mean we have
contacts we talked to all sorts of
people and it's completely fine this is
how it always goes it didn't happen and
it happened and is not a big problem
exactly but what I'm trying to get at is
that it seems like there's only two to
to change that to results of what's
going on what's gonna happen with this
impeachment which is one
he gets removed from the office and we
find out that you know you can't solicit
another government for help in an
election or two he does it and then the
rules of the game have changed so what
I'm insinuating is that someone in the
house on the Democratic side should test
that boundary instead of us pretending
like he didn't ask or maybe let's find
out if he did I would like to see
someone actually step up and you know
say hey Saudi Arabia if you want us to
prove you're your weapon sale which we
will you need to help us with corruption
or China you need to investigate
advantage trunk and then we'll help you
with the trade deal because it's Trump
who's the one negotiating all of that
stuff so yeah I mean you're it's an
interesting idea but Democrats are not
in a position to demand those things
because Trump and his administration are
the ones managing those relationships
you're a hunter you're entirely correct
which is but at the same time that's why
some why we didn't see the pretzel in
ski go on CNN he kind of waited to the
last moment holy I mean the Congress
would be able to step over because Trump
essentially is it the universal gateway
into the favor that he was asking for
all right I think I understand I think
it's an uphill battle unlikely to happen
but I appreciate the phone call very
much and and hope to hear from you again